hey everyone dear volume here and
welcome to my series in which i go over
the entire history of specific anime and
manga characters from a variety of
different series
in this video we are going to go over
the entire life and history of sugo
gutu inside of the jujutsu kaizen
universe but before we get into all of
that if you are new around here and want
to see more jiu-jitsu cars and another
anime content make sure you hit that
subscribe button and leave a like on the
video as well if you do enjoy my content
as it really helps out with the
algorithm but enough of that let's get
into the entire history of sergio ghetto
so nothing is really known about the
childhood of tsuguru ghetto but what we
do know is that he attended jujutsu
technical college along with shoko and
gojo and we are first introduced to him
in chapter 65 when during his second
year at jiu su tech geso
gojo and choco were sent to make sure
that maymay and udahime were okay
after not hearing from them for two
entire days after gojo's surprise
entrance in which he blows up the
building holding meimei and udahime they
quickly deal with the cursed spirit and
save the girls
once they arrive back at the school giro
attends a meeting with both shoko and
gojo where their teacher at the time
masamichi was scolding gojo for not
putting up a screen
and leaving the assistant manager behind
while still in the classroom
the group discussed the importance of
actually putting up a screen this
somehow turns into more or less an
argument about this strong protecting
the weak and the reason for being a
jujutsu sorcerer this ends up flymaxing
in a fight almost breaking out
only with masamichi showing up at the
breaking point and assigning ghido and
gojo
a special mission from the tengen the
two initially think that masamichi is
joking around but he discusses the
absolute importance of completing the
mission
and that both of them will have to be on
the lookout for mainly two groups of
people that are trying to stop the
merging of the star plasma vessel
after being informed by the teacher
about the mission at hand both of the
guys
gojo and geso head out after arriving at
the place where they're meant to meet
the vessel for their mission they see a
small explosion out of one of the
building's rooms then they see a young
lady who turns out to be the vessel
falling to the ground before she hits
the ground ghetto manages to use one of
her spirits to fly up and save her the
assassin
kyu sojo kokkun then confronts ghido
ghetto easily defeats the soldier
and shows cocoon a picture of his
defeated comrade through his phone once
the vessel wakes up who turns out to be
called rico omanai they introduce
themselves to her they then ask riko why
she's so happy even though she's going
to be in the merger and what she says
with the merger i will become master
tengan but master tengan will also
become me
my heart my spirit my all will live on
after the merging that is why she still
remains happy with the hope that she
will still somewhat remain alive forever
after going to rico school they make
contact with masamichi about the
circumstance they are in
after talking with masamichi ghetto
checks his surveillance spirits in which
as he is about to say if something
happens they'll immediately let me know
he notices that two of his spirits have
been exercised and immediately tells
gojo that they have to get rico now
keto encounters one of the two intruders
first the seemingly elderly man manages
to figure out what ghetto's ability is
and tries to counter but as he enters
guido's combat zone his life starts to
flash before his eyes and guido
easily defeats the man he then proceeds
to interrogate him on who he is whether
he's with the time vessel association
or with q and his small group once done
with his interrogation
ghetto meets up with masado and asks her
about riko's whereabouts
once the last intruder opposing masato
and ghetto finds out that riku is left
with gojo
he leaves to chase the pair ghetto calls
gojo and informed him of the situation
after they find out that masato has been
kidnapped hiro gojo and riko meet up to
discuss what the next plan of action is
they decide to save masato because rico
hasn't said her goodbyes yet immediately
after arriving at onikawa they saved
masato and instead of choosing to head
straight back they went to the beach and
decided to have some fun
guido and gojo discussed why the
kidnappers wanted to do the exchange in
onikawa until they needed to head off
but when they were about to leave rico
managed to convince gojo
and then in turn gojo kind of forced i
guess ghetto into staying one more day
they talk about sleep and if one of them
plans to stay awake all night to protect
rico in case of an assassin and if gojo
is strained after using his curse
technique constantly for four days once
they wake up the next day and arrive
back at the college therefore are taken
by surprise when an unknown assailant
showed up and stabbed gojo through the
chest from behind
while gojo holds off the sorcerer killer
ghetto takes rico and masado into
jujutsu tech and leads them into the
tomb of the star corridor
their ghetto lets rico say her goodbyes
to her friend masato kudai
and then enter the hall of the tombs of
the star getu explains to riku the route
that she must take
alone to master tengan's tomb and to her
sudden surprise that he also wouldn't
stop her if she wanted to leave riku
takes a moment and decides that she
wants to leave but in these moments
toji undetected to guido due to his
heavenly restriction had tailed the pair
after defeating gojo
as rico decided she wanted to leave toji
shoots his handgun hitting his target in
the head and killing rico get out
lost in thwart wondered why toji had
randomly shown up but before he can ask
toji proclaims that he has defeated gojo
and explains
on how he has done so ghetto enraged
summons spirits to attack toji
one after another toji effortlessly
takes out guido's highest ranking curses
and manages to deal
a critical wound but decides not to kill
him to stop an incident with all the
curses under ghetto's control escaping
and killing civilians
after toji had left with rico's body to
go claim the prize from the star plasma
association
shoko showed up and healed using her
reverse curse technique they then set
out for the star plasma group's
headquarters
once gojo had arrived at the
association's base he found out that not
only toji was dead
but that gojo was also still somehow
alive and that he was the one who killed
toji
while also taking back riko's body that
had just been delivered
before leaving gojo thought that they
should kill everyone there but the calm
and collected ghetto
said no and that it wouldn't matter
since the group would be disbanded
anyways
after a whole year passed giro who was
with shoko was helping gojo perfect his
new technique
after throwing a bunch of different
things at gojo and being curious about
how his technique exactly works
goju explains to them how he can
continuously activate it without harming
him
at all afterwards ghetto slowly starts
to subside into this darkness that we
see him shrouded in
throughout the jujutsu kaizen zero
series he said to himself
it's been a busy summer but there must
have been an influence of the constant
calamities we had last year
curve spirits were crawling around like
bugs i exercised and ingested
again and again exercised ingested
the taste of a cursed spirit that no one
else knows
like swallowing a whole cloth that was
used to wipe up vomit
exercised ingested and for who ever
since that day i've kept asking myself
what i saw then wasn't unusual
at all i was well aware of the ugliness
i already knew that and made the
decision to be a shaman despite it
don't falter as one who is strong you
must fulfill obligations
monkeys after this first slide
into darkness
ghetto meets with yuhaya bada you asked
guido if he should get any souvenirs on
this trip
in which giro agreed and said that he
might get something for gojo and get out
to share
after this giro asks you if he thinks he
can keep up being a shaman
while you was explaining why enjoy his
being a sorcerer yuki shows up and you
decides to leave them to talk alone
while he heads out on his mission with
nanami
once the two were left by themselves
they begin to talk about their own
personal objectives
and guitar explains to her the source
behind all cursed spirits and how to go
about creating a place
where curses don't exist and only
shamans do after yuki leaves realizing
that ghido actually never answered her
original question
ghetto went and met up with nanami who
was in the morgue mourning you's death
nanami explains to ghido how you was
killed during his mission
a few days later giro was sent to a
village to exercise the cursed spirit
thought to be causing mysterious
disappearances and strange deaths
instead of killing the girls who were
thought to be the reasoning behind the
murders
who turned out to be young shamans he
decided to massacre the entire village
instead
for wanting to kill the girls ghetto
then takes these girls and is made a
wanted man by the jujutsu headquarters
with the rules that he is now to be
executed on-site as a curse user
a few days later gideo meets with shoko
and explains to her something similar
to what he explained to yuki after
explaining that he wanted to kill
all non-sorcerers shoko has gojo come to
shinjuku to meet with ghetto geta was
confronted by a shot gojo on the streets
and ghetto nonchalantly explains that he
couldn't even make exceptions for his
parents
after gojo decides to not chase after
ghetto ghetto makes his way to meet with
the members of the star plasma
association
and explains that he is now in charge
from this moment this organization
belongs to him
with major discontent flowing through
the members ghetto decides to bring up
sonoda one of the representatives of the
association
and kills him to put his point across
now we skip forward to yuta
and his first year at jiu jitsu tech
girl releases a cursed spirit in
elementary school that ends up
swallowing two children
after yuda and maki are both captured
you to beat the cursed spirit with the
help of rika
three months later gideo heads to the
shopping district to witness the special
grade cursed spirit
reeker ghetto used a grade one cursed
spirit and had it fight toge and yuri to
see
if he would rely on rika's power after
yuda and anumake managed to defeat the
cursed spirit kiddo says that he was
hoping to see the infamous reeker and
that he should return yuda's id that he
snatched during the fight somehow
after this ghetto heads back to his
headquarters a few days after the
incident with yuta and anumaki
guido is helping a woman who is cursed
by a spirit ghetto ends up exercising
and ingesting the curse and is thanked
by the woman but can't hold himself back
from bad mouthing them and calling them
monkeys that can't even use jiu jitsu
after they leave
one of ghetto's followers shows up and
lets him know that the commanders are
here while on the way to his meeting one
of his donators kanamori shows up and
commands him to exercise his curse
for the amount of money that he has
donated to him get her remarks with one
of his followers
that he has been donated about 150
million yen but there haven't been any
donations for the last six months
ghetto then sets some small flee-sized
curses on kanamori and has him torn
apart
stating to his female follower that
non-sorcerers are just monkeys and their
time is now over
now it's time to realize the age of
sorcerers but first
they would have to destroy the
cornerstone of the jiu jitsu world
jiu jitsu high ghetto then decides to go
to jiu jitsu tech along with his group
he has instantly intercepted
by yuta and maki's group guido instantly
greets yuta
trying his best to sway him into joining
his cause which is killing all
non-sorcerers
sarado and masamichi along with meimei
and a bunch more faculty show up
and confront ghido they ask why he is
there and he steps away from yudha he
then declares to all those who are
gathered up there that he is declaring
a war on jiu-jitsu on december 24th
which is funnily enough the same day
that the movie is coming out for juju
200 the night parade
of a hundred demons will commence over
two thousand curses will be released
throughout two locations
one in shinjuku in tokyo and the other
at the jiu jitsu sacred land of kyoto he
then released a few cursed spirits and
escaped quickly with his
group on december 24th guido shows up at
jiu jutsu tech and kills off two
assistants
he states that his chances of winning
are about 30 but if his plan succeeds
and he kills yuda akotsu
so that he can capture the famous
special grey curse rika then his chances
will go up to 99
ghetto who is snuck into the school
without anyone knowing puts up a screen
around the school making it invisible to
the outside world after ghetto easily
deals with panda and yumake and maki
he engages yuta trying to kill him so
that he can steal the queen of curses
he explains to yuta that the weak bury
the strong because of their sheer
numbers
and that their pompous faces their
resemble monkeys make him want to vomit
ghido and yuda face off and ghetto
manages to break yuda's katana but yuda
hits back immediately and punches ghetto
in the face
throwing him to the ground yuda then
states why he needs to kill ghetto
realising yuda is quite strong
he sets his special grade imaginary
vengeful spirit tamamo
and every single one of his other curses
are numbering 4461
which he combines into one spirit using
his curse manipulation technique maximum
uzumaki
onto utah both yuta and rika have a
close moment and yuta ends up releasing
reika's power and shoots it at giddo all
of guido's curses are
exercised and his right arm and a part
of his shoulder are blasted off
because of his injuries gideo is forced
to retreat and proclaims that next time
she'll be his but sadly for ghetto he
encounters gojo as he's hobbling out of
an
alleyway giro and gojo have a small chat
about trust in which giro faces up about
the elementary school incident
and throws back gouda's id also
professing to gojo
that he was at the second incident with
yusu and nanumaki after this
giro was killed by gojo but his body is
never taken back to jiu-jitsu tech which
ends up developing into this swado
ghetto case
the last words giro chose to say were
it's just that
in this world i couldn't truly be happy
from the bottom of my heart
not really much of an explanation for
his actions but i'm sure it resonates
with some people
anyway i hope you will enjoy the entire
life of suguru ghetto if you are new
around here and want to see more
the lives of then make sure you hit that
subscribe button and leave a like on the
video as well
if you do enjoy my content as it really
helps out with the algorithm also feel
free to leave a comment down below with
what you thought about the entire life
that suguru ghetto led and what you
thought was his initial fall into
darkness was it before the village
massacre or during the year time skip or
even before that perhaps
but anyway for now it's been your
professional degenerate diavolo and i'll
see you all
in a bit bye
[Music]